- This is so weird, 'cause
you know, when you're friends
and family with someone
and you have 'em on
your show, it's awkward.
I ended up marrying her oldest son,
and you got stuck with me more.
- Thank goodness.
Thank goodness.
(audience applauds)
Yeah, I'll clap to that one, too.
- But I mean, out of
all the fun we've had,
I always have my little moments with you,
because I know we're
friends and we're family,
but you're always like that hero to me,
especially musically,
like, you're just a beast,
like, a pioneer for women,
like, it's insane.
- Thank you.
- And not just musically.
I think what's amazing
about your career is
you're a businesswoman,
you've conquered Broadway,
you've conquered TV,
you've conquered movies,
animated film.
I mean, you've done
everything you could possibly
want to do.
So my question is what
is the next mountain?
Because
you've already mastered everything.
- Well, I haven't mastered
or conquered anything,
I want y'all to know.
- Yes, you have.
- I've just gotten to participate.
People were nice enough
to let me be a part of.
I tell you what I'd really love to do.
- Okay.
I want to do an authentic Western movie
or a television show.
A Western.
- People would love that.
- I love Westerns.
- Oh my God, there's so many avenues now.
Netflix, Amazon,
all the things.
- Everywhere.
- We can make this happen.
- Kelly Clarkson said so, right there.
- I mean, I think people would love that.
- I do too, I do too.